[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
майстерня творчості пані солі та ясенка
А ми сьогодні на самій до нашого золота
дайте побігайчик
зайчик-побігайчик привіт зайчик
маленький у такому почухаю тут А нічого
Там будуть Зайчик може вже друзі знають
що ми сьогодні будемо вчитись малювати
це така підказочка
о мабуть будемо вчитися малювати котика
юстинку
зайчика
Ой Клас Я не вмію малювати зайчика але я
дуже люблю зайчиків Ох який милий
давайте друзі вчитися разом Давай
показуй станок Спочатку ми малюємо тут
ось такий горбик малюємо горбик ось це
буде спинка зайчика
ось тут ми починаємо малювати ловушку
вушко гаразд потім тут ли
Ага і потім тута знизу Ще його маленьку
ручку маленьку ручку потім мене до кінця
доводимо ще один горбик і потім будемо
лінію і ось
тут так так дуже мало Юстя от в тебе
схоже на зайчика а в мене не дуже схожий
Да що треба ставити покажу будь ласка
ось тут я посмішку маленьку ось тут ще
робимо контур всередині його вушка і в
нього лапці малюємо маленьку морквочку
маленьку морквочку
так а давай ми тепер намалюємо його
трохи більше з іншого боку щоб друзі
добре побачили
ми намалювали маленького зайчика Тепер
давай намалюємо Великого давай так
давайте малювати тепер Великого зайця
Великого горбика робимо правильно
потім велике вушко потім велике вушко
потім ми ліки лице велика личко
потім велику руку велику руку потім
великий горбик вниз не до кінця
я зробила до кінця
я потім
ось таку лапку юстинку в тебе такий
гарний зайчик вийшов у мене не дуже
така красива так друзі нас всіх Все
красиво правильно їсти Потім очко потім
по сніжку і потім Контр у вушку і потім
моркву можна більше морквинку бо який то
зайчик без моркви правда
так Ну а що давай тут лапки так от
домалюємо ніби лапка
Отож давайте покажемо друзям що в нас
вийшло
маленький зайчик
і вийшов великий зайчик
Ось так друзі А ще середній зайчик і
середній зайчик Ми всі з вами зайчики
па-па па-па
Привіт друзі
усім Привіт
зайченятко зі мною юстинка теж І я пані
Софія сьогодні Ми продовжуємо читати
нашу книгу про друзів коли друзі поруч
пригадуєте таку
і Сьогодні в нас буде дуже смачна
історія знаєте чого смачна тому що вона
називається
тортик для зайки
Ось така історія Ну ми починати
щось я зголодніла зітхнула зайка
погладжуючи свій животик що бурчав може
у друзів є чим зі мною поділитися
подумала зайка і пішла до друзів Привіт
песику сказала Зайка ти їси таке смачне
яблуко А чи можеш дати мені шматочок
пробач але я не збирався ні з ким
ділитися відповів пасік Я хочу з'їсти
ціле яблуко сам
[музика]
пішла далі наша зайка до друзів і бачимо
мишку Привіт Мишко сказала Зайка ти п'єш
такий смачний лимонад А чи можеш дати
мені ковточок
знаєш відповіла Мишка я не можу
поділитися з тобою я збиралась випити
цей лимонад сама Ну що ж наша зайка
трішки засмутилась але пішла далі і
зустріла мавпочку каже Вона до мавпочки
Привіт мавпочку
Ти їси таку смачну булочку А чи даси
мені відкусити шматочок
Вибач відповіла мавпочка але я не можу
поділитись тобою Я збираюсь їсти булочку
сама
пішла зайка додому
А друзі помітили що зайка засмутилася
Шкода що ми не поділилися із зайкою
зітхнула мишка
зайка завжди така добра до нас закривали
мавпочка і песика
справжній друг наша зайка Треба її якось
розрадити розвеселити
А давайте зробимо великий торт
запропонувала мишка
точно морквяний торт
адже зайка любить моркву зайченятко
хрумчик Ти теж любиш моркву Я дуже люблю
Клас звісно зайці дуже люблять моркву
їсти і друзі вирішили зробити такий
сюрприз
мишка песик і мавпочка вирушили на кухню
і заходилися робити торт
Спочатку вони замісили тісто а потім
почали збивати солодкі вершки
облизуючи пальчики
Який гарний торт зрадів песик і як же
смачно він пахне скоріше віднесімо наш
морквяний торт
Ух ти ням-ням
тортик вже почали друзі нести Привіт
Зайко боязко почала мавпочка нам дуже
шкода що ми не змогли поділитись тобою
нашими ласощами і ми хочемо виправити це
тому приготували для тебе великий
морквяний торт
[музика]
як чудово який смачний морквяний торт
зраділа зайка Це мій улюблений торт у
песика мишки і мавпочки аж за бурчало в
животиках адже торт мав такий апетитний
вигляд
торт такий великий сказала зайка Нумо
ділити його між усіма друзями
песик Мишка і мавпочка аж застрибали з
радості зайка така добра
і зайка розділила торт і дала кожному по
шматочку такого смачного морквяного
торта друзі ще не куштували
ось Яка смачна і апетитна історія
трапилася із друзями сьогодні
[музика]
малята А чи було колись у вас така що ви
не хотіли ділитися із кимось наприклад
ваша улюблена машинка або лялька
пригадуєте така такий Іноді може
траплятися наприклад хтось з вас
попросив погратися вашою улюбленою
іграшкою але ви У цей момент не хотіли
її давати що ж тоді робити Ви знаєте
спершу ви дійсно можете не дати цю
іграшку тому що Це ваша особиста річ
Але щоб не образити когось ви можете
зробити цій людині сюрприз от як наші
звірята із книги коли в друзі поруч Що
вони зробили вони підготували для зайки
морквяний торт
ви можете зробити такий сюрприз також
для когось зі своїх друзів
тож просто сказати добре я пізніше з
тобою цим поділюся і можете ще додати що
я для тебе можу зробити пізніше сюрприз
тож можеш зачекати поки я пограюсь а
тоді ти
[музика]
Ось як ми можемо допомогти комусь іншому
Ну що ж з вами була пані Софія і юстинка
і наше Зайченя будемо прощатись па-па
[музика]